you know royce said to me before the
show i got it i got this new one
and it's it beats dayton hypernova and i
and i um
i didn't believe royce i was like that's
a
you're you're making some pretty tall
claims here but
this is better than dayton hyper now
because dane hypernova doesn't even go
out like
dayton hypernova doesn't leave the house
these two at least are
men about town holy [ __ ]
his boyfriend just got arrested and he
asked the other cops what's your
astrology side what's your astrology sad
will you say your astrology sign for me
is that okay well i would i think it was
my
what he's so like hey what all these
times
it's not against you i'm all for you
it's okay i have no idea honestly
can i ask you what your mouth is i'll
turn it off okay
he said he turned off the phone he
didn't by the way can i ask you what
month you were born
sat down
okay okay i'm gonna turn the fall or not
i'm just gonna he didn't turn it off
i was gonna turn but i'll just
a thirsty very thirsty oh this person is
a gems this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
you know what i mean
so go ahead and get out for me now okay
uh oh
yeah so then he uh it's just he has he's
on medication and stuff he's got a
mental illness and that's all
go ahead and get out for me now okay
you're not
uh before all this action that you're
about to see
when we were when i was driving wait the
action's still coming
oh no that was he he did it backwards
that was the action oh it says
i just got a vision he's a big sports
fan at least
of a of a car going in the water
and i was like what i was like well you
know there's brown to be cars going in
the water because these places are off
listen to how [ __ ] up he is in this
definitely [ __ ] up very pilled out
flooded
and stuff and what color was it he goes
you don't believe me and i said well
it's not that let's just record you
saying it before
if you do get to see one in the water or
whatever
and you're the expert what do you think
he's on
earlier with i think meth and coke but
what do you think now i think he's annex
zanny to calm down varies in like not
quite
um not quite like buzzing and euphoric
like you would be on uh
on [ __ ] opiates it sounds like xanax
he's like i don't know at least he's a
good catholic boy
well you know sure enough after all this
action that you're about to see
babe
after he well he gets arrested
definitely and you'll see it
um i got the footage in this video
i was free to go and i'm all lost my gps
system takes me
crazy places on the outskirts of who
knows because there's barricades
everywhere because
closed in rows half closed and half not
closed so i'm confused
half had cones into signs half didn't so
look
we could we could we could skip this
part sure knows how to spin a good yarn
there's there's we're gonna skip this
part here um
there's another one more video that i do
want to show but this is um
this is def here's two channels so this
is one channel i'm gonna post a link in
here
it's indigo party monster relationship
with price footage
which is you know pretty pretty good and
you know come videos in here
now mike i think what the problem is
you're seeing here is you're judging
them
oh my god oh yeah but wait i want to see
what the car ended up under water
there's no video of that
wait what yeah so this person
missed the best part but there's this
so you remember how with dayton
hypernova we were saying like man the
police probably know this house
of course yeah because it's just
constant hey
what's up earl 911 called
sir boy unfortunately
you got a call out here yes
did you see this crap i can see that yes
sir
on the back of my hand somewhere it
hurts
right here
wait till you see the cop uh
you come out of the elevator or the
stairs take a right and
there's a door with a bunch of names on
it and you go in there and straight to
the window and ask for the on-call
prosecutor
it's not the branch when it's two guys
it's a fight it's a fist fight
and they'll help assist you with getting
a warrant for mr
i thought i was doing good look i have a
bruise right here on my head i'm gonna
cry i'm not right here on my head he
beat
mike he beats me in this house he beats
so now they're taking pictures of them
right as they do with domestic
branch other signs filled by cancer and
it makes
people see the pictures see if you're
okay with them yes there's that one
you see the redness right there daft
it's swollen it's proceeding to be
a ruse later on or whatever
processing so now look we're judging
them on the rough times right
here's the thing mike
this is this person's main channel it's
called
psychic dashton the vampire slayer so
his name is
dashton the vampire slayer
dashton the vampire slayer here's the
other link for dashton the vampire
slayer i hate dashton
well mike you're seeing here's the thing
we're judging them based on their bad
times
you want to judge them based on their
good times
yes
yeah of course you do guys with me
miranda
going to prank call peewee's playhouse
i'm going to get them good i'm going to
get them real
good
[Applause]
hey pee wee go get your car cause the uh
motor's running you better go catch it
i hate to tell you miranda i don't have
a car
so my letter's not running
i haven't
miranda you know what's funny
i think your lipstick's running you know
what
you better go get it
so for those who are not watching and
seeing mercer's face but
besides i've explained um the dashton
has his hair down makeup on um the other
gentleman i don't know
the gentleman's name jj maybe you could
help me is wearing white face makeup and
doing a peewee herman impression
this is a pee herman impression
that um they're doing you're not gonna
be able to hear with your headphones off
you're not gonna be able to hear the
with your headphones off it's a pretty
spot on peewee
please playhouse and they do have
something in common with paul rubin
what's the problem mike you you're
you're afraid of two guys that love each
other
this is this this is you're afraid of
two guys that love each other now
this is
this might be the weirdest [ __ ] i've
we've ever played on this show
then now will you agree with me when i
said
that um that i said this is
this destroys dayton hypernova this
makes dayton hypernova
this watching these guys video makes
watching a dayton hypernova video
feel like watching a dusty pogen video
like now now i just think of dayton
hyper nova
as a calm laid-back cool fella
compared to these two holy [ __ ] he said
there's always a bigger
you're obnoxious oh miranda you know
what's
funny i know you are really am i
i could care less about me noxious
that's my name
is that pewdie herman
i wish we were a famous celebrity couple
does he even do the hair
does he do that at all because that's
more peewee
we have to be a famous lovely couple you
have to marry me miranda
this looks like found footage after it
really does
and who's miranda
is that a character from beauty i think
maybe i don't remember i was always more
of a dotty guy
i was more of a genie guy to be honest
with you like people slept on dottie but
thought he could get it a lot of people
slept on dottie i meant
over and over saint daddy was a
just getting [ __ ] deep at the bike
shop when it closed
why do you think cowboy curtis was
always showing up
oh [ __ ] i need to marry be a famous
celebrity
i am famous miranda
i'm pewdiepie
i can be a
famous celebrity with miranda
make a heck of like a love mega
hiker it's mecca like a high mecha hiney
ho
first off you're you [ __ ] such a big
peewee fan you can't even get that right
that's the genie that's the genie in the
box mike
that amazon box that they cut a hole in
stick their head
see that amazon box that they stuck
their pop their little head through
this is disturbing people are saying
it's miranda sings i guess is a
youtube channel oh so these they're all
over the place
got it so they're imitating a youtuber
talking to pee-wee herman
got it cool okay cool
have a happy zombie day
pb herman i mean
edward scissorhands why did you fulfill
my wishes to become a famous celebrity
couple
and marry me
yes it's me miranda
and now i'm going over oh it gets better
can i be honest with you all right look
guys little scorpion
[ __ ] boy okay merch
i've done some [ __ ] drags in my day
so when people go like oh look at this
look it must be
meth must be drugs drugs does not
explain this level of craziness right
like
like you've observed enough people on
crazy amounts of drugs before
he's observed me on drugs before you can
tell i'm on drugs because i'm like
i'm totally on drugs right now sam's on
drugs everyone
but this is like th
this is stuff that's in there when
they're sober it's just they're doing
drugs
this is i don't even know what's
happening
no oh yeah well what about this
because you asked
me too
here's a look at my hair oh
how sweet i love you but why don't you
have the hair
edward you can edwards because you're my
barber but he had the hair
in this in the next frame he just didn't
have the wig cut it off and then he cut
his hair
thank i love you
i want to say i already said this once
but i'm going to say it again yes
these are somebody's sons yeah
you know what i mean like imagine you're
a father and you find this
footage of your son
if i did my [ __ ] brain matter would
be all over the wall the next day
because at that point you go wow
i really really [ __ ] up like i
couldn't even just have a great son
which would have been fine you know what
i mean i couldn't even have like
a son who just happens to enjoy some
meth i might even have been able to live
with that but this
is like next levels of embarrassing
i see they've uh i see they they shop at
jason kessler electronics
look mike we could stop right here
there's gonna be plenty more of this
coming up i promise you there'll be
plenty more
we got time we still got time left
okay i want to find out what happens to
peewee or
whatever hey man if you want to find out
by the power invested in john b genie me
you are husband pee-wee herman and your
wife
miranda sings i shall close these doors
and you can kiss each other 125 views
and y'all are married yeah we got that
we we got that you pronounce the man and
wife this is like
i i don't even know how to i don't even
know how to
what to make of this this is like this
is if this was
parody it would be next level right
oh yeah no but the reason okay so when i
first saw this right i figured oh these
this is a [ __ ] joke these guys are
[ __ ] around but the moment the police
showed up i'm like
oh [ __ ] this is real
you may now kiss the bride
oh miranda i haven't seen a horror movie
that has been this scary in my life like
this is
this is horror show stuff if i did want
to like just scar somebody for life too
and you just
kidnap them and then they and when they
come to these videos are playing
that would be you wouldn't even have to
kill anybody they would just die of a
heart attack they would just die of pure
panic it is amazing this
this 269 subscribers by the way so this
is like
a fresh channel then the other one is
just he documents the abuse
he beats me beats me in the stuff pee
wee herman beats me
in this house he beats me in this house
so okay now i have a question for you i
know they're both terrible
i trust me i get it
who's worse oh the one with the goatees
clearly worked so dashed
well i don't know actually yeah i don't
know this is
because that that pee wee herman
impression is also a [ __ ] travesty
so you would say so i don't know the
other guy's name
can i okay god no you're right they're
both equally awful like i can't even
really
put my finger on which one's worse i
wouldn't recommend touching them
um he actually dies the hairs of his
barbies
here we go we're gonna blow dry the hair
let it out mike it's okay it's okay go
ahead let it out
because it's such a tiny doll with such
a small amount of air
i'm sorry dashton continue
okay what i'm gonna do with this is
transfer this hair onto this barbie doll
well here is the process you rip the
head off the door come in
you get these nose clipper things
i don't know what they're called what is
happening
you wanted to you can made a
frankenstein barbie what's your problem
here mike
you can put it in a ponytail uh
frankenstein was a doctor
sorry there's always that one guy
so it's dashton and the other one is he
calls himself the narcissist
oh like lex luger
narcissus what color
should i get for this
that's his mom by the way who he lives
with
[Music]
get this knight tail and i pop
this one out about two of them out this
isn't together at all dude you want to
see something
look at the channel look at the channel
this is so dark
this is the bowels of hell subscribe
look at the channel
people that make this many videos are
usually very sick people